Kamala Harris
last night was on the Seth Meyer show
and no for listen it sounds ridiculous
but if ever there was a place that could
benefit from her fake laugh
it's the Seth Meyer show correctamundo I
mean of all the places in the world you
know she'll she'll give you the fake
laugh when you're talking about people
dying crossing the border she gave me
the fake laugh when she's talking about
World War III and anything in between
but yeah on the Seth Meyer show it's
actually appropriate because they
benefit from a lot of fake laughter over
there that is a really terrible show
like Seth Meyers is about as funny as an
orphanage on fire on Christmas day it's
just depressing stuff it's hard to watch
but it was vintage Kamala in that you
know mountains of nervous energy a lot
of hypocrisy and just weapons-grade
stupidity and I want to start there
because Kamala was talking about on Seth
Meyers the Border you know she's the
borders are she's in charge of the
entire she's the tsar of the Border
has Kamala Harris been to the Border
she's in charge of the answer would be
no no but it didn't stop her from
telling us the Border was a byproduct of
the Trump Administration and the fact
that there was a dereliction of Duty on
the Republican side get her out get her
out of here I say it all the time man we
are living in the death of Shame do you
know what kind of Shameless sociopath
you have to be
to make Republicans the problem at the
border understand the Republicans have
made securing the border the centerpiece
of their campaign in 2016 in 2020 again
here in the midterms it's like the one
thing they talk about the most like you
know if you go to see like Chumbawamba
you're always going to hear I get
knocked down but I get up again because
it's their one song the Republicans when
it comes to the Border almost sound like
a one-hit wonder because they recognize
how Primal it is to every single man
woman and child living in this country
they talk about it a lot support the men
and women in uniform support the Border
stop spending cut taxes these are the
only things you ever hear out of their
mouths but here is Kamala trying to pass
the buck put on the old QB Jersey got
under huddle blue 28 and here she is
passing the buck on immigration clip 25.
I just think it's an absolute
dereliction of Duty if you see a problem
and if we agree that that we need to
address it
then if you're a leader participate in a
solution
right
she is a fraud a phony a woman without a
moral core a regular two-faced really
mouth politician who Swings with the win
she thinks it's a dereliction of Duty if
you see a problem
and the need to address it and you don't
participate you ought to be ashamed of
yourself yo you are the borders are
and you haven't been to the Border
okay you don't talk to anyone about
dereliction of Duty that's bananas
okay imagine that you're in charge of
driving the fire truck ladder company
22. that's your job you drive the fire
truck
but two years have gone by and you
haven't shown up to a single solitary
fire not once
but you have the nerve to get on TV and
say the other side is a dereliction of
Duty Kamala Harris you suck are you
kidding me like that's embarrassing they
should hurt on the inside a little bit
get a little throw up in the mouth I
mean just sound like as you say it like
it's a dereliction a duty by the
Republic
[Applause]
and here she is saying the last
Administration they broke the
immigration system that's what they did
clip 26. when we first came in office
the first bill that we proposed was for
a pathway for citizenship was to fix a
broken immigration system which was
broken under the previous administration
participate in the solution because we
are offering Solutions but instead this
gamesmanship
with real human beings who
trust us
I don't have any friends I mean what a
loser
okay
this game's been shipped with real human
beings she's talking about people
getting on air-conditioned buses and
shipped to other states
and she says it as if that's somehow a
worse alternative
then you know allowing them to drown in
rivers as she has allowing them to
suffocate and tractor trailers as she
has allowing 30 percent of the women who
cross this border illegally to get
sexually assaulted as she has somehow
it's the gamesmanship on the Republican
side you got to be worried about right
now is what she wants you to understand
Kamala is a lying sociopath fact checked
like an actual sociopath though
okay when you really think about her
ability to get in front of a camera and
address millions of people well probably
not millions of people at Seth Meyers
but her willingness to get in front of a
camera and address dozens of people
and say the Republicans are the problem
it's Republican gamesmanship understand
the Republican gamesmanship which is
relocating migrants to Sanctuary cities
you know what a sanctuary City means it
means we're willing to take in the
migrants no one is illegal in our city
come on down
until they came on down and the
Democrats are like oh hell no
can't be coming on down it's a strain on
our resources this is a humanitarian
crisis what do you mean air-conditioned
buses we can't have air condition but I
liked it better when they were back in
the rivers whose idea was the buses it's
inhumane I tell you time was you could
Jam 83 people under the floorboards of a
tractor-trailer those were the good old
days now they got americonditioned
they're coming up putting them in hotels
what do you mean okay it's such fraud
Democrats are so full of crap they
really are and here she is she's saying
the migrant bussing is political theater
clip 27. I mean we're talking about
people who have fleed great harm they've
fled great harm
and they are coming here seeking Refuge
and
talk about political theater I mean
playing games with people's lives like
with their lives you know there were
mothers with sleeping babies getting off
those buses
oh this mothers with sleeping babies
coming off those buses again not ideal
but you know what else they're doing
with those sleeping babies
waiting across the river and drowning
okay getting smuggled by drug cartels
that sexually assault them forced them
to mule drugs into the country do you
know why child separation exists at our
Southern border okay it began under
George W bush it continued under Barack
Obama I don't see you doing any better
in the booty department and it went on
under Donald Trump and of course okay
they kept that policy in place after
Biden won the election I don't remember
that ever happening but it did okay
Biden's in charge right now
unfortunately
and understand that the reason they
separate families at the border is
because ninety percent of the time the
kid isn't with his family the kid isn't
with his legal guardian he is with an
asylum Seeker who knows he has a much
higher chance of getting into the
country if he's accompanied by a minor
he's a lousy dad but he's right so
understand okay child separation is
there to protect the child to make sure
he is not with someone taking advantage
of him abusing him okay that's why it
exists okay to this day you don't have a
single solitary story
of a family that was separated at the
border and never got back together it's
like voter suppression you can't show me
one legal voter who is denied the right
to vote it doesn't exist you know the
old adage when you have the facts pound
the facts when you got nothing pound the
table the Democrats are always pounding
the table when it comes to stupid
emotionless stories like this put up
or shut up but they don't shut up when
she talks about playing games with
people's lives yeah incentivizing them
to come here illegally
is playing games with their lives okay
with the last Administration tried to do
was Secure the Border you don't have to
like them I don't care I'm not a
recruiter for the Republican party but
you understand that the Democrats voted
for border wall funding okay they voted
for it under Barack Obama they voted for
it under George W bush why because the
border is the front door to the house
okay look at it like the front door to
your house you shut the door and lock it
at night because you want to know who's
coming in or out of the house it's not
because you're racist it's because
you're not an idiot but in this instance
we have idiots in charge complete and
total I mean 100 morons I agree with
that okay running this Administration
and they like to Pivot to things that
tug on your heartstrings though it's
people's lives you're playing games with
you know how dare they and why do they
want to do that they'd rather you be
madder
at a guy like Rhonda Sanchez or Greg
Abbott
then be matter at them the ones who are
green lighting the drug cartels to turn
our border into a 15 billion dollar
trafficking industry the the southern
border of our country is worth 15
billion dollars in Commerce to drug
traffickers right now okay after the
previous administration had implemented
a remain in Mexico policy that
completely took the teeth out of the
cartels
because you understand when Asylum
Seekers had to remain in Mexico until
they got into the country
the cartels couldn't guarantee them safe
passage into the country
okay by repealing that policy because
there was racists we got to be building
bridges not walls such performative
stupidity but by repealing that policy
it allowed everybody who got caught at
our Southern border to come into the
country oh your legal fine all right
well let's just process yeah you're
gonna have a trial in six months and you
better come back for that trial to make
sure your Asylum case is granted ninety
percent of the people who cross the
border illegally don't show up their
Asylum hearing why would you you're
already in the country
why are you going to show up for a legal
hearing that could result in you leaving
the country these people already broke
the law once to get in they're not going
to start following it now that they're
here illegally do you understand
and by taking away policies like oh I
don't know stopping a border wall ending
remain in Mexico not enforcing title 42.
the Democrats sent a message they turned
our Southern border into the college bar
that doesn't check ID you all remember
going to a bar in college when you were
underage and you're like no no go to
this place you can get in with like a
library card all of a sudden the line
was around the block because all of the
people who shouldn't be in bars knew
there was a way in and they started
showing up to them hey this is great and
that's the people at the southern border
I have great empathy for them they're
fleeing real food insecurity real
problems real oppression not fake
American stuff okay but understand
there's a legal way to do this so they
don't strain the resources of our system
but more importantly if we're being
honest so they don't drown in rivers
suffocating tractor trailers and get
sexually assaulted by drug cartels
things Kamala Harris doesn't really care
about and for being honest which is why
she's going after Republicans instead of
the borders are who just so happens to
be her
foreign